[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Mélissa metissent toujours rêvé
dites jamais que je vous ai dit ça ou
Mélissa
alors qu'elle est moitié nue
descendez ça c'est défendu oh c'est
indécent
elle criait bien entendu
personne ne descend
sous la soif de sa jupe fendue en
zoomant gros plat
tout un tas d'individus
fumes noir et blanc
mais tu se disent à descente pointue
dites jamais que je vous ai dit ça ou
Mélissa veux-tu
descendez ça c'est défendu master chez
les gens
inscrivait bien entendu
il y a jamais d'argent
escrime du temps perdu personne ne
l'entend
la police c'est tout défendu 10 ans
qu'elle a tort et
[Musique]
vous êtes dit ça tous Mélissa
métisse
se dit toujours des vertus du jamais que
je vous ai dit ça je vous ai jamais vu
le matin derrière ces canulysse alors je
vends des longues vues mais si jamais
mais ça c'est ça là c'est moi qui vous
tue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]